[Music]
so you were in ottawa you finished your
degree you're doing massage therapy
you're now fairly bilingual now i'm
fairly bilingual and jordan gives me a
call
when was the last time you talked to him
i
used to see him at christmas you know
i'd come home at christmas every year
and then
i didn't for a couple of years and
then he said he was going to move to
ottawa and i thought oh that'd be nice
and then he didn't he got a job in
edmonton so he didn't come so then i
kind of thought well i'm just going to
pick up my life and and go forward yeah
so i i
went out with a fellow and lived with
him for a couple of years and then i was
finishing my degree and i got a phone
call from george that he was in montreal
that he was doing his phd and he was
going to mcgill and so i went there for
thanksgiving
and he looked like he was doing all
right and he was a lot taller well he
was a lot taller a year after high
school i met him in fairview he got out
of his car and he got out of his car for
like a second or two longer than usual
because he wasn't a foot dollar
he still wasn't marriable at that point
though he was pretty much a wild man at
that point but once i got to mcgill he
looked like he wasn't quite as much of a
wild man and that he was getting a life
and that he had a plan and i thought
that it was a part there was a
possibility that maybe we could make a
go of it because he had already asked me
to marry him a couple of times by then
when at christmas um at new year's i
think at new year's i said yes that was
the last time what i don't remember
hearing about this i thought he wrote it
to you in a letter he did he wrote me a
letter and and asked me to marry him
there and i thought is this guy for real
yeah kind of
that's not very romantic where's the
knee
and the ring yeah it's like well we did
live 3000 miles apart yeah and that you
know back then to call home was uh
it wasn't you didn't have a cell phone
you didn't have a cell phone plan or
anything
it's of money for a long long distance
and we didn't have it i didn't have any
extra money neither did he yeah and it
is kind of romantic yeah he wrote me i
think that used to be the way it was
people would write letters i imagine
yeah
a lot of letter writing you know love
letters remember you've heard of yeah
yeah yeah so he wrote me i think he was
probably going to europe and wanted to
know if i wanted to get go with him and
also get married but i thought maybe he
was joking because it was written in
kind of a joking way you're probably
nervous yeah you could pass it off as a
joke if you said no just in case
that's right
so i didn't quite know how to take it so
i just kind of left that there
and one time he asked me and i said
maybe
i wasn't ready yet i didn't want to say
no but i wasn't ready to say yes i still
had to see which way his life
well when we got married i was 27. so
did he ask you the first time when
you're like 25 or something oh maybe 23.
oh okay that's pretty young that's
pretty young yeah i didn't know that oh
yeah yeah you know it started like that
early like the asking the asking yeah
the asking started kind of early you
just tortured him for like four years
when he started to it looked like he was
going to start to have some girlfriends
i married him
as soon as you saw other
women moving in that's funny yeah
he was and he was just starting to feel
like confident and everything and i'm
very married
[Laughter]
kind of advice or what kind of
suggestions do you have for
teenagers trying to
grow up so in the you know 18 17 18 19
year range what kind of experiences do
they have to have or choices do they
have to make in order to
grow up
great question and great challenge for
for all of us adults and parents out
there
you know i mean now more than ever
you know
we create something a picture or
something and then we upload it and we
send it out to the world and we and wait
am i gonna get thumbs up thumbs down
what are the comments gonna be
and if
they come in thumbs up
we have a great day
so confident it's awesome they come in
thumbs down
we're crushed
so the kids days are so much more uh um
i guess
you know
what the rest of the world assumes or
has to say about them or what they put
out determines
so much of who they are and how they see
their own gratification
in life um
whether how much they respect themselves
how much they care about themselves how
much they trust themselves
um or not
and that's different than when i
grew up you know and different than the
generations that grew up before me so
it's a wonderful tool
but
how
how children and millennials can find
some discernment in that to what does
matter what doesn't matter look i'm 51
years old
i've got a family of three i've got
non-negotiable things that i've built my
life that i love and are
much more important to me than what
someone feels
but at the same time does it feel better
to me at 51 to read a good review on my
book rather than a bad review do i my am
i happy yes
i'm susceptible to that for a movie i do
and even in that you know i've learned
to read something and go oh this critic
was writing a bad review before he ever
saw the movie he just didn't like me you
know what i mean and i've learned to see
that but still it it oh
or
you know oh i'm gonna now go now
even if you're not in a position where i
am where
of a fame and celebrity where people
recognize me children receive something
receive negative comments or somebody
says words to them
they go into the world thinking that the
whole world everyone they interact with
might be thinking that way
you know our mind very quickly goes to
somebody that says something negative
that's why we rubber neck you know and
when highways turn down and slow down to
20 miles an hour our mind immediately
goes to the lowest common denominator
much quicker than the highest common
diameter or someone and it's not true
it's not a true reflection
and it's it's a false mirror that kids
have now that there are more false
mirrors of how they see themselves and
how they're seen in the world
you can get them you know sometimes we
have the mirrors to the upside those
those skinny mirrors on beverly hills on
in beverly hills at the gucci store
which make us look just slimmer and true
better oh that's such a good idea you
know what i mean and then sometimes most
of the times it's easier to go to that
mirror that makes us look
shorter fatter wider uglier than we
actually actually are well
that's how so many views are going out
and having engaged in the world based
off of what somebody out there said
mostly strangers
with a lot of them who
were like that critic who's going to
write a bad critique on my movie anyway
before it even saw it because
you've got so many people out there that
they need the little hit of feeling more
confident and the only way they get it
is by putting you down
which is short money you know it doesn't
last it's like it's it's the it's the
guy at the party that tells the joke
come here tell us the joke
on so-and-so over there eric over there
right and we all laugh but i told it out
of school because i wouldn't say it in
front of eric and we all laugh but soon
as you walk away from the group you
disrespect me more
you lost respect it's short money you
know yeah got to laugh was the life of
the moment but for the long term you
walk away losing respect for me
so
that that that a lot of that goes on uh
now with creating how kids feel about
themselves i also want to remind us all
of this
and i know when we're young we think
we're going to live forever et cetera et
cetera but
just remember out there every comment
that you put down or everywhere you go
on this thing called the internet and
online and things you say those are
gonna outlive you they're gonna outlive
all of us
and that's
writing that's that's gonna that's
already writing the story that's gonna
introduce us at our eulogy and after
we're gone
so think about them because they i think
we feel kids feel we often feel like
they're impermanent
but they're not anymore
they're very permanent
yeah
that's a bit scary
what are you doing with your kids and
social media do you have limits
yeah are you controlling that i can't
imagine being in middle school
with instagram that sounds like hell to
me
i mean do you want anyone to yeah do
children need to be that
that conscious
again that mirror that's not necessarily
a true a true mirror before they've
actually found
who they are and feel who they are
and walk by in a real mirror and
actually go oh i look
how i feel i feel how i look this is a
true representation of me what i'm
putting out is reverbing and coming back
to me
in symbatico well you're getting the ig
world you're not getting that again it
can go inflated or it can go deflated it
can go into the asset section or the
debit but it's not usually true
and to put that on a child where
you know i still work in all of in my
work that i do again at 51 i'm trying to
close i've always been trying to close
the gap between
what does i want to do and what are you
actually receiving
there's been a gap at that time to my
life all the time i do it in you know it
literally in movies what i want to do
and i'm going that was that was the take
the director goes no come over here and
have a look and i'll look at the monitor
and go oh geez
that's not that does not look like what
i intended to do now that either means i
didn't do what i intended to do
or
the camera wasn't placed in a way that
it was received that way so it wasn't a
true impression so i'm trying to close
those those gaps
child's children today with ig and stuff
there's always a gap to the upside to in
the inflated side or or the debit side
and that's that's dangerous tough
territory to navigate when you're just
trying to find yourself i know with our
kids
with um i don't want our children to see
something in a movie or tv show
that they don't have some context of
understanding how that would work in
life i don't want to learn it for the
first time
through a fictional representation in
someone's storytelling i want them to
understand
that
oh that's how
that's how life could be i don't want to
see
a sex scene until they understand
the the what what sex is
for instance i don't want to learn that
and have those questions seeing it for
the first time outside of what me and
their mother can try and teach them or i
want to be the one saying no let's have
a look at this book this book explains
it really well in a true and healthy and
constructive way that's how i want to be
the first to give them that that's hard
to keep a lid on it's it's a wild wild
west out there with kids
you know and they get online
uh um they see something the ads pop up
that looks good and tapping on that does
not take them where
they think they want it to go and all of
a sudden next thing you know they're
down the rabbit hole and i'm like i said
i'm 51 and responsible i have trouble
with it
yeah what do you what what are you what
are you been doing last 40 minutes you
came here for something deliberate and
intentional and 40 minutes later you
know where you're so far from that you
actually almost forgot what you came in
here to look for
you know so we're trying to tell them
that the internet is like a neighborhood
they were trying to tell them that when
you go out there's good and there's bad
people that want to do they want to do
good and bad things and you can't trust
everyone that's just waving you know and
said hey come over here have some candy
you know um and so we do put limits on
we give them a time they have you know
it's like screen time
amounts they can have and not have and
then also trying to now the challenge is
like well all right levi if you're
making a song on garageband
true
that
i'm going to say that that's more
constructive than
going online and
checking stuff out if you're
intentionally going to use a tool that's
still technically screen time
but okay you know so allow that they
have they have messages they have about
five friends as well as their mother and
their grandmothers that they can
communicate with
we
know those parents and we know those and
we know those kids um
they don't you know uh they can't buy
anything
you know online with that unless it
comes to me and i have to i have to get
i have to be able to to buy it um but we
try to limit it and we notice how much
you know
i don't want them to do it so much that
they forget loving to do a puzzle
which they also love to do you know what
i mean inside yeah yeah something analog
that that that they like um
and you know or or playing a board game
you know sometimes they get too much
screen time and that's like not enough
it's not enough uh it's not enough of a
buzz it doesn't have enough lights and
action and sound and you're like
that can actually be kind of cool you
want to play dominoes
so i'm not trying to be a you know i
gotta check in i'm 51 i won't be no
buddy dud about it you know i want to
embrace this these tools they have but
we're very constant about where they go
and we've had a few slip ups the kids
have had a few slip ups that we found
out about
let me try to let them know hey we kind
of know every if you're going to go
somewhere where you you know or that
question that thing you typed in son
we're not telling you it's a bad
question to have
but we're telling you we'd rather you
come to mom and dad and let's talk to
you about that queen you're not gonna
get in trouble for asking that question
or wanting to see those things but don't
go there because there's a lot of bad
artists in there there's a lot of bad
painters and they're gonna show you
things that are that are false so just
come to us and we'll sit down and find
some true versions of what it is you're
looking for and we'll talk about it and
you won't get in trouble you know and
they're like you're you know
i'm so glad that that
ended
before i like i got to a computer i
think when i was in grade six there was
msn and things so
i didn't have it as a kid but i had it
in middle school i'm so glad my parents
didn't have oversight yet that didn't
that didn't happen but we didn't have
phones writing screens so it was a bit
different it was like a certain amount
of computer time but you couldn't
oversee google searches thank goodness
not that i won't be doing that to my
daughter but i'm just glad that i missed
that
so i guess you did you did quite a
switch in the last couple of years and
you're doing a lot more of your comedy
on politics yeah just political things
that are going on which isn't that
surprising given the state of especially
north america but
the state of the us with covet and
everything but what is it that made you
change from more of that like health and
wellness comedy to the political
commentary commentary i would say
yeah i love that i had no intention of
getting into politics i never found it
interesting i always found it a waste of
time and it's just like
these faces
these figure heads that aren't doing
anything just make a lot of noise never
interested in that
then our freedom started getting taken
away
that impacted me
and and specifically when kovid stopped
becoming a medical issue and started
becoming a political issue
which still blows my mind
it also tells me
it ain't a medical issue
if they're just making a political issue
that's how i interpret it so
when kovitt became a political issue
rather than a medical issue
that's when i really started notice my
freedoms are getting taken away
my friends freedoms are getting taken
away
in ways that are
sure as hell not justified
and then april 7th of last year
my wife and i found out we're pregnant
and i i know you've got a little one and
i'm sure you've got your similar
experience but
there is something flipped inside of me
just like this you know three million
year old primal father instinct
of
i want to make this world as good of a
place as possible
not just for me but for my son
so as i saw freedoms being eroded away
and of course like if someone
someone's vision goes forward you can
see not just
here's the freedoms taken away today but
you can see
where that will go if it's not checked
and
and so having my son on the way became
very motivating to me and
and
at the time the idea of like all right
like
apparently now cove is a political issue
and any time you go into politics you
divide the audience piss off a bunch of
people
at that time i was thinking like oh
i don't want to piss my audience off
but
the pain of not saying what i need to
say would be far greater than the pain
of losing some audience or whatever so
i just i stayed dedicated to speaking my
unapologetic perspective
and
calling
bs and calling tyrancy
where i saw it
it doesn't mean i'm always right
definitely
right some of the time uh certainly
employ the odds
so i stayed
dedicated to that and
and
to me we have nothing without freedom so
it's kind of like all right in the face
of such since i've been censored i've
been warned by all the platforms and of
course i do my best to know our what are
the red flags that the big tech tyrants
will just automatically eject you out of
youtube or facebook i want to do my best
to reach the people so i need to be
where the people are but yeah but i also
can't be silenced so
the censorship i think it's made me a
better comedian because i've had to
become more artful in saying what i have
to say without saying the thing
absolutely directly that'll get me
censored
so
when i looked at that it's like all
right my son's coming into the world
censorship's ramping up it's already
been happening to me i've people i know
have been de-platformed
but i i just knew like all right
we
we have nothing without freedom so i
would rather speak my truth and do my
best to help people and help the world
which means i'm helping my son
into the future
i'd rather do that and risk losing the
online empire i've built up i would
rather speak my truth
and have to pick up cans on the side of
the highway to feed my family
in the name of doing my best to make the
world better for my sons
so um the freedom switch got flipped in
me last year
and which by the way i mentioned i was
afraid of losing audience my audience
just exponentially grew there's nothing
i've ever done that's been better for
audience growth than
be unapologetic with my truth
and in seeing how my audience has grown
so much i've realized
the the perspectives i'm speaking
you know if people aren't watching my
stuff and my audience isn't growing by
leaps and bounds because i'm some
good-looking guy
it's growing so much because what i am
saying
has become the voice for many voiceless
people who either
don't have a platform
and or their views aren't represented by
any of the media that they're exposed to
so
people need a voice and at times we find
surrogates to voice our voice they're
saying what we have to say so
it's been an honor to become that
for people and of course
what's most important is for people to
find their voice like you got to voice
what you need to voice i'll be the
surrogate hopefully an inspiration for a
little while but you've got to be brave
enough to voice your voice as well but
anyway so that's been a a pretty
exciting
um occurrence to see along the way the
past year or so that i've
ventured into the arena of politics
because
that's where
the
the
treasure of freedom
has been plopped
yes i like i like the way you put that
i was gonna ask you a question on how
you've avoided
being canceled
can you tell me is it possible to tell
me what you're not allowed to talk about
i feel like that's something like are
there topics that you artfully avoid
specifically yeah you know certainly um
and i'll say them so explicitly because
i want to get you censored michaela
just kidding
no certainly vaccines that is just that
is the most censored topic i mean you
get doctors on youtube talking about
vaccines and they ban them it's like
holy hell a doctor what the hell
um
so you can't say anything about vaccines
that's not towing the propaganda
mainstream media
narrative about it
um youtube has also been very explicit
of you can't
say any misinformation about coven
which means you can't speak any
information about kovid that's not
towing the propaganda lines
and
you know certainly the election here in
the u.s
last fall into the new year
that was
a very hot topic i had to be very
careful around that and
yeah so
those are certainly some of the topics
and
i'm trying to think
what else i i know
climate change is coming down the
pipeline already it's
it's
quite censorable if you're questioning
any of the narratives around climate
change and
and i know
you know thanks to something like the
undercover work of project veritas
exposing the corruption at cnn you know
the cnn has literally said recorded in
undercover tape
that
they will be pumping climate change in
order to create more fear in people
and
so yeah like a anymore like i i really i
love questioning
fear-based narratives and anyway climate
change is another one coming down the
pipeline that
uh they will be excited to censor
uh okay changing topics slightly what is
what is your that's good to know that's
kind of what i figured
um i started this
section on my podcast called opposing
views where i'll have one view on
and the opposite view on yeah
and so i'm seeing if that's okay
so far it seems to be okay like here's
the one like alternative realistically
alternative view and here's the
mainstream view but i'm showing both of
them so yeah that seems to be okay for
now i mean thank you for doing that like
god help us all if there's only one
point of view like and god like i don't
i don't even want just my point of view
like
i've never been right about everything
in my life so
i mean you just think of how crappy the
world would be if you only had your
point of view you never had contrasting
views it's just like a muscle that never
has a weight to lift
that muscle is not going to get stronger
it's going to get weaker smaller it's
going to atrophy
and i think our minds and our
perspectives are
like that times 10.
you went through
absolutely i mean i can't imagine it
unimaginable hell and you've
like you just said you've managed to
forgive everybody which is that alone is
incredible because um i say most people
who go through hardships
are resentful and angry um even if
that's not necessarily good for them
it's hard to not be angry so
how did you
like how did you manage
okay one thing did you think you were
ever going to be able to get out
first i want to second everything you
said everything you said
it's really
it's really right
no
i resigned to my
faith
on many occasions when they came to me
one day
richard zuli is a cop
from chicago and he took over my torture
and this is not something against
muslims or arabs or african
he he was involved in torturing american
people too
so she's
like his job when he came to me and he
told me he's going to arrest my mother
and put her in a
military
prison
with only men
you know
at that point
i know i had nothing to lose
there is no more no more anything i i
was like i'm ready i'm ready i can tell
you everything you want i can sign every
confession you chose
you know because the last thing i saw
from my mother
is when the police came to my home
and they took me
and i could see her in the rearview
mirror
as i pulled away she was praying
frantically you know this stasp
and she was like praying frantically and
i turned right and then she disappeared
forever i never ever get to see my
mother again
and she died in pain and suffering and i
never i never actually
michaela i never understood the
magnitude of her pain you know i was
young i didn't care but now i have my
son ahmed
and i can never imagine
that someone
would come to me and take away my son
and this is not canada or the u.s or a
free country where they come to say you
know what we arrest your son because of
a b and c he was involved in drugs he
did this
someone would understand there is pain
but someone would understand
and but this is someone who say i'm
taking your son and i'm not explaining
to you anything and i don't owe you any
explanation
then i told him
i signed everything
and then sergeant shali told me
to sign that i was planning to attack cn
tower
i never heard before that of cn tower
later on i was told it was in i think
toronto
because i lived in montreal
and i told him no problem and i signed a
complete false confession and i put my
signature and i was
they said they will give me a death
penalty as you saw in the movie and
this is like horrible but let me go back
to your question of resilience
you know michaela
we always need to ask ourselves what
does matter most in life
i spent eight months
in the prison of darkness
in jordan when i was rendered to jordan
i didn't know days nights i was in a
basement
most of the time not all the time but
most of the time and i lost count
of this
they took me
from jordan to the airport i was
blindfolded i couldn't see i couldn't
hear your mouth
and they start to cut open my clothes
scissors first time
you know i
this is technique i don't know about
and then they stripped me naked
then they put me in diapers
i knew
then that my life
will change forever i picture myself you
know in one of these violent american
prisons
dying you know
no one care about me
no one will ever hear about me in my
whole life in a split of second run
through my head my whole life
what i regretted most michaela
is any bad words i told anyone
any bad comments i told anyone any bad
gesture i told anyone that what i
regretted i never regretted not having
money i never agreed that i'd have a
million dollar in my account i never
agreed that i didn't marry that very
hard chick i
met at in college or anything
none of that mattered what mattered
to me was how good i was to people and i
took it upon myself if allah if god
ever
gives me a chance to live again
i will be nice to people that i will be
nice and mikayla this is not easy to be
nice because
people push you
not to be nice
you know but it pays off to be nice to
people
and i'm trying my hardest and i'm not
saying i'm successful all the time but
this is
this is
how do you call it in english this is
something i took upon myself basically
and i'm going to
to do my best to be nice to people to
forgive everyone
and to help as much as i could
and i don't care about your background i
don't care about your religion i don't
care about the color of your skin
or your political color
with whom your heart beats the most
i will show you okay can i can i do it
along with you yes yes of course and you
can
yeah
you guys want to do it yes yes
tell me how you feel afterwards okay we
just do one round i recommend you do it
uh jordan you do it whenever you feel
anxiety or a deep neurological
deficiency or whatever yes okay well
that means i should be doing it about
two or three hundred times a day i would
say i i think if you do this
then it's like staying away a long a
longer and longer time
but let's do it okay
okay here we are relaxed
take a deep breath
all in and let it go
all in
let it go
i will take the telephone then see how
long you've got to stay first round 90
seconds
one and a half minutes
after the exhalation without uh without
air in the lungs
for 90 seconds no force
that is deeply into the neurology you
will see
just follow me and i will show you here
on the timer that you do so
and i will talk while well and
and say what is happening because you
feel it
okay
all right there we go
this by the way this technique
uh with this we
changed fundamentally
uh medical sides of our perspective of
what we can do within our
physiological depth
against bacteria virus depression
neurological diseases etc
but now you will experience
so
i will show the on the camera the
the numbers
oh god i don't know if i can do that
there we go so now you got it fully in
let it go
fully
let it go
pull in
let it go
keep on going the mind goes with the
breath
don't mind about nothing else but your
breath
the mind is a big player so let it be
with the breath
julian let it go
pull in
let it go
pull it in
let it go
keep on going fully in
let it go
become light-headed go on pull it
let it go
18 times more
fully in
let it go
fully in
let it go
16 more
yeah
let him go
fully in
letting go 13
become light headed loom in the body
don't mind just go
it takes just a couple of minutes what
we do
to arrive at a deep impact on our
physiology
deeper than in science was thought
possible
it's all here
then after
the feeling because feeling is
understanding we can talk
eight more just go
it's a workout
seven juliette
let it go
boolean
six more
letting go
pull in
letting go
now now comes the last one fully it
let it go
and stop after the exhalation
close your mouth
no smuggling just witness
there is no need for breathing
the carbon dioxide has been blown off ph
level uh is a really high there is no
trigger to breathe
only the brain could reflex but don't
just be in the peace it's the
parasympathetic nervous system
deep peace
no need for breathing
just witness
you're deep into the physiology of your
being
the way nature meant it to be
because you are right now in deep deep
stress but you're a tranquil
it's a paradox
we are really deep into our physiology
right now
no force
and you changed your biochemistry
and now the adrenal axis
is shooting out
through all the body resets the body
any defect is being neutralized
getting rid off
10 seconds more
nine
six three
two
one
fully it
fully in and hold
fully
oh
squeeze it to your head
three
two
one let it go
there we are
god i hated that
yeah sure
but this is the way we you know what you
hit more this neurological defect yes
and this is the way through deep stress
activated consciously while being okay
because it's maybe altered because of
the stress of the podcast and
so yeah
did we hold our breath for 90 seconds
you could yes for 90 seconds
you guys did 90 seconds here it's all
there
i probably did 85 seconds and took a
tiny little breath yeah that's what
happened to me too
this is round number one right number
two we would go two minutes round number
three two and a half
number four three minutes
of hauling exhale
you got to do this then you will see how
do you feel
well i'm not wandering around the room
uncontrollably moving and screaming
so
you know that's better than three or
four hours of my day
i'm still able to stay calm and sit here
and talk to you
exactly that's an accomplishment now
you gotta go even deeper and so in four
rounds you will be able to reach
after exhalation that is
there is a understanding principle
after exhalation means there is no air
anymore in the lungs and you exhale
completely
yeah almost completely
like i found i found if you if you
exhale all the way and then you kind of
bring your stomach up
underneath your ribs yes um that helps i
got taught that earlier this year it
kind of helps
in yoga that is the contraction
it's all you know it's old knowledge
but this is all new
and that it is true science makes it
uh trust worthy it's data it shows that
we are
activating the immune system through
this deep stress the adrenal axis
suddenly spikes
while you are in control
how many breaths did you have us take
about 30
30 30 breaths and then a minute and then
and so with your with your
your advice is to do the 30 breaths and
the 90 minutes of breath holding 90
seconds 90 seconds of breath holding yes
around that
and then
what i advise is this
go without force
i want to get into the bad parts about
being in the public eye when you're
little because it can destroy people
like you you see it
from the sidelines so what were the good
parts
[Applause]
it's a long pause a moment of silence um
the good parts were
yeah i mean i think it did it did teach
me
a good work ethic i think you know i
don't have to be asked twice to do
anything i think i'm really
self-motivated and driven um
and
and then i and i made some good friends
i made some really good friends um
and and also you know what i shouldn't i
shouldn't i think there's more i think
it's like what i'm doing now you know
writing and directing is adjacent
and
i don't know what i would have done
otherwise so so who's to say but i do
think that it's helpful to have
i i already kind of have a
somewhat of a running start
on this career because i know well i
know the industry kind of works somewhat
like this although it's very different
as an actor because as an actor
everybody kind of babies you and treats
you like oh they can't know anything
because they're sensitive and like
nobody tells you anything
um so it's it's sort of like a
it's it's definitely a more narrow point
of view i think to be an actor in the
entertainment industry but it's also
adjacent i think it was helpful in terms
of like switching to the career that i
wanted to switch to yeah so that's fair
uh yeah what about what about the bad
parts
that sounds easier um bad it certainly
is bad parts i mean there's a lot of um
there's a lot of abuse that happens i
work with an incredibly emotionally
abusive producer um
like i mean even talking about it now my
my face gets hot thinking of it just
because
you know he'd say things like you guys
won't you guys will work you would work
at yogurtland if you didn't work for me
and he would just scream how old were
you i was uh when i started the show was
13.
does yogurt land even higher people when
they're 13.
is that even a reasonable thing to say
the real questions thank you
exactly it's like um he was just he was
like a comically like the bad teacher or
whatever you would expect in like an
over-the-top
broad family comedy that's what he
seemed like very vilnius and almost like
mustache twirly in his kind of
personality
um
so yeah so there's there's just like in
there's abuse which is a very on the
nose bad and then there's also i think
it leads to a sense of entitlement
um where it's like
if you have so much at a young age you
think that that's reality like my
reality when i was 13 was that everybody
cared what i had to say my reality when
i was 13 was that like people were
interested in me just because i was on
tv
not because i had interesting things to
say not because i was saying anything of
merit or value and i think it leads or
for me i should say it definitely led to
this idea of like well things will just
be we'll just keep working out we'll
think well it's like you don't have to
try as hard and formulate your own
opinions and your own point of view as
much because you just think well if i
post this picture and it gets 500 000
likes i must be great that's like let's
tone it down you're not that great
sweetheart let's
get some intro corners
i mean that's got to be
that's got to be difficult to understand
if you have a whole bunch of people
watching you or recognizing you i mean
when you went on this
out on the street i you got approached
right
i mean it got to a level that was so
intense it would just i mean there's
paparazzi and like clusters of people
any anywhere that's like an act like a
public you know a restaurant like can't
eat
without people constantly they it just
it for me it was really frustrating i
think i think for some people they can
kind of
i you know i don't i don't think
anybody's made for fame like i don't
think that there's i don't think that
there's anybody who's made to thrive in
it but i think there are some people
that are more able to tolerate it um and
are just like better equipped with their
emotional and mental tools to handle it
and i don't think i was and it just made
me feel like i was going to explode all
the time i was so anxious
oh yeah well having an anxiety disorder
and then being approached all the time
and being recognized everywhere
sounds sounds anxiety provoking
right not not a not a recipe for success
no and i find i know that you know i
remember i think it was
eminem he came out with something and he
he got really angry at being approached
at a restaurant or something
and me as a kid i was like well like
that's kind of what you get for being in
the pub like i think there's a level of
i don't i wouldn't want to say like
resentment or anger for people looking
in but they're kind of like well you're
a celebrity like what do you expect
and then i know i've noticed through
mainly being around my dad
is and i'm not putting any negativity
there because most people who approach
him are really like really kind and it's
been overwhelmingly positive but it's
still like
you know sometimes when you're having
dinner it's like i just want to have
dinner
so sure it's weird it's a weird
situation
i'm curious about that too because like
with with you know your dad specifically
but i would imagine like i mean he's
changed my life i've done this i've done
his self-authoring suite three times i
do it every year oh my god i have given
it as a gift to everybody that i know i
just think it's so helpful in terms of
like getting you in check with yourself
and
it's it's the most realistic approach to
like accomplishing your goals and
getting your life on track
that i've ever seen it's like why would
you know what i mean why was i i just i
i i want everybody i know to do it oh
that's that's cool to hear yeah i think
it's so helpful but um but so i i would
imagine like if i saw you down on the
street or something i would be
approaching him for this thing that he's
made this thing that he's done um
i i prevented fame i really did because
it was like people were coming at me
constantly for a thing that i was
ashamed to be a part of
um you know i was on a show that i
thought was
trash like i just did i just thought
this is so shitty this is so bad i don't
want to go onto this overlit kids show
set and like scream my lines and just
like whoa carly like everything just
felt
just so ridiculous
um
so so for me it was like when people
were constantly approaching approaching
me it just felt like
god about this dumb piece of trash that
i don't even like why is this
like it just felt so
i mean i know that's super i think it's
a super unlikable thing to say but it
really is is oh no it's just you know
it's just kind of sad right um i get i
think i kind of get where you're coming
from too because for an actor too you're
portraying people who you aren't
so then you might be approached i don't
know but you might be approached on the
street uh from someone who treats you
like the character you're portraying or
if somebody like dad wouldn't exactly
have that happen sure sure yeah i mean
people would come up to me i played like
kind of a
punky
teen on tv a girl would bend a juvie and
at the time i was like
14 but seemed more like a seven year old
emotional like i was very emotionally
underdeveloped so people are coming up
to me being like hey sam like and i'm
going hi like just nervous
and they're like oh you're not cool
never mind oh man that's sad
that's all right
that's all right uh i've done i did
self-authoring once it takes that it
takes a lot of self-discipline i would
say to go through the exercises because
they're not
fun per se and they're not frilly
so to hear you've done it three times
it's pretty impressive
yeah i literally have my i have my full
my filled out ones in my drawer in front
of me because i read them frequently so
that i stay on track i mean i take it
very seriously that's such a good idea
so what are your goals then what do you
want to do
um i think i've done a pretty good job
my last ones were like write a play was
my first run i wrote a play uh didn't do
anything with it didn't like it um
better regulate jealousy anger and fear
that was a huge one that's hard they've
come so far with that like they were
really [ __ ] hard emotions for me to
regulate before i just
didn't know how to handle them and i've
taken a lot of actions therapy and
whatnot to try and get better at them
and i've worked really hard
the podcast is what got shane kicked off
of snl yes yes big time okay yeah it was
so what what happened what happened
there were you just brought into a room
and they asked you if you would repent
and you said no and then they fired you
like what happened well they
and there was a lot of people at nbc
that were like very like you need to
repent right now and then there were
other people that were very like
understanding and cool about it and they
were like we get it we know that's not
who you are but you have like you have
to say something in order for us to keep
this alive to see if we can get you on
to the show so yeah they handed me like
a
the night that it broke the news broke
so i got announced on snl and then
within six hours i was getting canceled
like right away and uh which is pretty
funny but uh it was like as soon as i
was in the public eye people were like
get him out
get rid of this guy
uh but yeah they sent me like a a quote
like here's what you need to tweet out
say this say what i said was inexcusable
i'm terribly sorry all this stuff and it
was like well it's not it's not
inexcusable and if i say that what i
said here
was in fact wrong and bad literally
everything i've ever said was
in the same tone i'm joking so and i and
i i what you said there earlier about
like i don't want to hurt anybody of
course i don't want to hurt anybody you
know like so when when i found out what
i said affected people like i think
there were some people being honest that
it did hurt them to read those words and
to hear those words and i do i was sorry
about that like i don't want to hurt
anybody with this but i was just goofing
yeah that's a distinction man
that's the weirdest thing when people
read that stuff and they're just like
they just jump to the wildest conclusion
that it's like oh my god this person
like as if i mean the situation was
painted as if we were like two like
korean war vets being like
asians oh yeah yeah it was just it was
crazy i was reading it being like this
is insane if you've actually watched
this it would be like very hard to reach
second it'd be very crazy to think there
was that many people being hey it was
really funny like it's weird to think
that how many people would tune into
like two thirty year old men being like
another thing i don't like it's like
yeah it's crazy it's insanity but you
know that's kind of what people are
going for right now yeah it's it's
tricky too because in order to be funny
you kind of have to walk the line
between verging on extremely
inappropriate right so if you're going
to be a comedian then it's going to be
nearly impossible to continue to be
funny without occasionally stepping you
know
over the line or not being funny by
being too far from the line but it's
like how do you continue to do comedy if
there's so much risk to your
careers like what um what was the
fallout from from that oh i mean it was
it's like also i want to say this about
that like the way we speak like when
somebody asks you about 1776
like it's almost all irony we're joking
we're sitting here ironically being like
they better not take our guns neither of
us have a gun like we're joking
you have a shotgun now yeah my dad gave
it to me legal transfer father-son sick
but i don't really think just in case
anybody listening cares
yeah i'll never touch it i carried a gun
once my wife's actually really good
trained with guns and stuff and i we
went shooting i i dropped the gun in the
parking lot and you know that's that's
been my gun
yeah that's not great no
um
but the fallout was like i mean even and
also to go back to like when they tell
you to repent and they're like you you
have to throw yourself to the mob and
say sorry it's like first off they're
never gonna accept your apology ever i
could have said the most well
well-thought-out well-written
tweet and they're going to be like fu no
matter what they'll be like [ __ ] this
guy um and there there's also people
that like care about comedy and i hate
to be one of those guys that's like i i
do love this like art form
you know i hate to call it an art form
but there's you have to have integrity
and you have to be like no i can't i
can't say sorry for this like i can't
there's too many people i respect that
would that would uh hate me for that
including probably myself it's also it's
like taking when people know they didn't
do something they take like a guilty
plea just to reduce the sentence it's
like you know understandable if you're
facing like actually 10 years in prison
but it's like yeah just [ __ ] it's
like you know and i that was something
when i especially when i saw you do that
of just being like you know using that
opportunity just drop i thought it was a
pretty wicked joke in the tweet being
like i was more of a whatever like mad
tv guy or whatever yeah it's like dude
that's the whole point of the job and
like you know they
would have done it better i could have
made it funnier but it was dude there's
so much pressure i was sorry
dude yeah and i took it so seriously
because it was it was very serious i
mean the whole world it felt like was
like this guy's a piece of [ __ ] and uh
yeah thankfully i have friends that were
you know like no you're not so that was
nice yeah i talk a bit about on the
podcast about people who've gone through
like you got it hit pretty hard but
people have gone through experiences
where everyone online suddenly hates
them and we are not like as people we're
not built for that amount of scrutiny
and hatred even though it's like people
online although you had it in real life
too right but
we're not we're not made for that amount
of stress
so it kills like it's it's not
it actually does kill people um i had
somebody reached out to me and
they got canceled and it was kind of
small they were in like a hospital
institution and they said something
inappropriate
and they got canceled online and they
didn't even have an audience and they
ended up killing themselves so like it's
not it's not casual it really does it's
really hard on people and you see it
happen to celebrities and you're like
yeah well they can handle it but it
hurts it's hard no it does and it's uh
it's i'm only like now coming to terms
with it it's been like almost two years
and it's like it's been like a year and
a half and it's been like uh there was
definitely trauma there's like i there's
like it [ __ ] you up it does well it's
also crazy too like the large newspapers
who you know will carry these things out
like you know just not even thinking
about it they're obsessed with this idea
of inequity and lack of power and
inequality and it's like they can
literally write whatever they want about
anybody and you couldn't go on and be
like well actually there's no you can't
do it and it's just it's [ __ ] it's
total [ __ ] and it's like you know
hopefully more people will just stop
taking it seriously because it literally
i was reading the economist yesterday
and one of the main articles was like
well what is china is what china is
doing to the uyghurs is that really
genocide though i don't think it is and
we should be careful how we phrase that
we don't want to mess up our trade with
our ally and it's like who wrote this
who was there like well we don't want to
mess up our trade with china you know
it's like it's crazy it's [ __ ] it's
i believe it's paid for and it's written
by people who just don't have like
normal people best interest at heart and
it's it's nonsense dude and it's it's
crazy what you can do they also have no
problem just totally misquoting you like
uh oh yeah just totally misquoting like
there was there's one and it was in like
time it wasn't like time they they
quoted me and matt did a show in philly
where you made fun of people behind
their backs on a screen so there was a
screen where there was a group text
where whoever was on stage was getting
made fun of and everybody in the
audience could see the group tech and uh
besides the comedian performing besides
the comedian performing so you would say
like the worst things possible because
it was also anonymous the group text so
people were saying like really messed up
things and then this lady from uh
a philadelphia magazine interviewed us
after and i said uh we're learning that
you can make fun of asian people and
nobody has a problem with it which and
then the rest of the quote is which is
very hypocritical but when they quoted
me all they said was you can make fun of
asian people and that was in like time
magazine and it's like you guys you
deliberately left out the rest of the
quote
there's some real utility in
shouldering the sort of responsibility
that stops you from wasting time and you
asked about negative elements of having
children i feel i think
in some ways similar to russell at least
with regards to what he said so far is
there was virtually nothing about it
that was negative as far as i was
concerned um
i suppose i
i
was somewhat
um
it was difficult to sort out
how the attention was going to be split
in the household i missed your mother
when she was so occupied with the
infants
but having children more than made up
for that and
you know kids get a bad rap and people
think of them as
an impediment to freedom and it's such a
foolish way of thinking because it's so
remarkable to have children and you can
have the best relationship
you have the opportunity of having the
best relationship with anyone you've
ever had in your life when you have
children and then all also
someone is finally more important than
you
you know i mean hopefully when you get
married or you fall in love with someone
they're as important as you or perhaps
even more so but when you have children
it's definitively the case that now
someone is more important than you and
that's
that's such a relief and it is a
it is a crucial part of maturation to
have that happen
and and i don't believe that people i'll
get pilloried for this or maybe you will
because it's your podcast i can take the
blame i can handle it
i don't think it's possible to grow up
without having children
oh
it's unlikely
he's still got it
what's that
as if he's still got it he can still
drop a bond mop that's gonna stir people
up
yeah well i it's hard to grow up until
someone's more important than you
so
why would you why would you why wouldn't
you continue being siberic and
and and living at least to some degree
for pleasure
so
it's true the children are amazing and
so everyone out there who's thinking
about having children you should do it
because they're they add
they add to your life and then when
you're older like me i'm 60 almost 60
now i have grandchildren now
and i can't imagine what my life how
empty my life might be without
that and more of that on the way so
yeah
i know some rather brilliant people as
i'm sure you both do that have
a foregone or decided against or unable
to have children
i suppose
the values that brought to the surface
in parenthood perhaps
duty
devotion and perhaps if there is a sort
of some transcendent component to your
life and i don't mean that in
necessarily in a spiritual way but
it's difficult to avoid the connotations
of that word then perhaps perhaps
maturation is possible
if you take for example like a
straightforward uh mendicants life
monasticism
celibacy devotion in a very uh
explicit way to god then would you
say that they are unable to to reach
maturity or what if it was a secular
version like devotion to the arts or to
a sort of a political cause do not think
that that could well of course
that reminds me of something i wanted to
talk to you about i read your book
mentors which is this book right here
and
one of the things that it made me think
about was
i've thought for a long while that
the
one of the processes that marks the
transition from childhood to adulthood
is
apprenticeship
and so one of the things nietzsche said
about the catholic church was that
the european mind this is speaking in
nietzsche's voice the european mind
disciplined itself by
adhering to a single interpretive
strategy for centuries to explain
everything under the conditions on
to explain everything using the axioms
of a single intellectual system and that
discipline disciplined the european mind
and enabled it then to go off and use
other disciplinary strategies to
discover other
to discover other ways of dealing with
the world maybe to develop science for
example and nietzsche was very convinced
that you had to enslave yourself in one
manner or another before you could be
free and that's an apprenticeship motif
and to me that's what you explored in
your book mentors
you know you you present yourself i
believe as someone who was striving in
various ways to mature
and that you identified people who came
into your life as targets for emulation
that could impose a discipline on you
and help you mature you would hunger for
that like like people do
and yes i do think that
if you don't have children there are
other disciplinary strategies that you
can use to further your maturation but
it isn't obvious to me that any of them
are as profound as having children and i
mean i've had a good career and i've
i've been very interested in
intellectual pursuits as well and i
suppose have disciplined myself in some
manner because of that but i still stand
by my um statement about children
they're in a different category of of
profundity
it's partly because you have to take on
so much responsibility when you have
children is it the sacrifice too i mean
if you think about people who
work in churches or what russell was
saying about
you know people who devote themselves to
god and it's kind of what they do is
kind of sacrificial and i suppose part
of what you do when you have kids is
sacrifice that hedonistic
part if you're going to be a good parent
so
is is part of what helps you mature the
sacrifice associated with having
children or is it something else i don't
know if that's part of what helps you
mature or if that's a definition of
maturation
is that it's a sacrificial act but you
know people often think of sacrifice in
terms of loss but the reason you
sacrifice fundamentally is to gain
something higher that's that's the
sacrificial motif you give up something
that's that's attractive in the present
but but the purpose of the sacrifices is
to is to
to organize things
more effectively at a higher level of
being
so and that is a that is maturation that
that's the forestalling of immediate
pleasure for medium to long-term
um well-being and maybe
for more than you as well
okay
um
i have a question
even though i know it's not my podcast
and
when you transduce a metaphysical idea
like
sacrifice and sacrifices as an evocation
of a greater power further down the line
and you transduce it into materialist
and rational rationalist terms perhaps
to make it more relevant to a cultural
group that don't even think in that way
anymore do you think that
we
risk missing
part and the essential part of the
mystery that much of the devotional life
by its nature doesn't have a a direct uh
translation in secularism i.e of course
yes you know i've heard you say before
jordan that it's as if there were a
father that's a stern father that's
going to guide you and discipline you
and chide you into being a stronger man
or woman but like um but
i feel too
that there is something that what that
through sacrifice we are also
acknowledging that on this plane of
being on this plane of being all our
needs cannot be met in fact really all
we can do is generate need and by sort
of sacrificing food or sacrificing like
sacrificing something important
we reaffirm our connection to the
sublime
okay well i think that
whenever you
bring a
transcendent concept in some sense down
to earth
you risk
inappropriately constraining it if you
assume that your act of bringing it down
to earth has explained it fully
so i don't believe that my explanation
of sacrifice explains it fully and so i
think you can retain that
you can retain the ineff
you can retain the advantages of
ineffability
for example if if i
assess a
piece of literature or film
for
and make its metaphysical
presumptions
more explicit
i don't believe that that necessarily
takes away from the film it it can
because it can be reductionistic but it
can add an additional
by furthering understanding it can add
an additional layer of of utility to the
to the experience i've tried to do that
with the biblical lectures i've done for
example i i'm not trying to explain
everything away although i do think that
generally speaking you should use the
simplest explanation that's at hand
so it's a risk but
but
hopefully it can be
a risk that is fundamentally productive
yeah i reckon that i said i suppose that
mentorship and
education is dependent on crossing this
space between the ineffable and the at
least palpable or the apprehendable
justice details that's the thing is that
if the ineffable stays entirely
ineffable then you can't put it to use
and
i think you're absolutely right that the
mentorship does that because
and there's a profound religious
instinct there and i think it was really
operating in you you you make reference
to it a number of times for example you
have
by your own admission a strong tendency
to
romanticize the women in your
in your life you say you deify them in
some sense or maybe more accurately you
perceive them that way to begin with and
then over time
in some sense the stars fall away from
your eyes but that's the action of an
instinct that would be the anima
projection from a union perspective is
that there's a an instinct in you that's
pushing you towards development and the
way it manifests itself is by
illuminating
certain elements of your experience and
those might be
that might occur for example when you
meet a male figure who you admire who
you then start to imitate it's it's
the deep workings of your unconscious
illuminate that figure and make him say
stand out against the background because
you've apprehended that there's
something about his pattern of being
that addresses a lack in yours and the
same thing can happen in romantic
relationships and and that can also not
be purely illusory you know in some
sense when you when you have a romantic
relationship with someone you are
chasing the divine in each other now
both of you may fall short and the
relationship may fall apart but by
seeing the divine in the person that you
fall in love with you also invite them
to manifest that and by opening the door
to that they're actually more likely to
manifest it
it's very complex it's very complex and
sophisticated instinct
i understand this i understand this i
have experienced this i recognize that i
have spent a lot of time projecting
through my inability to comprehend my
own psychic energies i've projected onto
another resources that were available
perhaps through tutelage within myself
one of the mentors i write about in that
book who's like has been incredibly
valuable in my life when we first met
like by you know synchronicity or chance
gave me a copy of the robert johnson's
book on gold and inner gold which is a
sort of an essay on mentorship and
having you know holding one another's
goal
um
and i think yes that how mentorship has
functioned in my life has
i've gained a great deal of perspective
i've understood that they are kind of uh
psychic uh
cynic decays holding for me a space
holding meaning i recognize the
fallibility of these people that i uh
like adore or aspire to
but
in my psyche they function as
coordinates i was just talking to a
brilliant therapist today in therapy and
like a and he said that you know that
you don't need to overcome your father
and mother in the physical world with
them you need to overcome the imprint of
them in your psyche and i said yes in a
sense they are hollowed out carapaces in
reality i don't mean that of any
disrespect to my actual mother and
father but like the the mother and
father that i deal with and live in my
psychic landscape they don't live in
essex england you know
um so like i recognize yes that we can
use relationship as an external
coordinate to activate dormant psychic
energies
so
there's a kind of reductionism in that
too in some sense right because by by by
doing that you reduce the
the
the experience of the divine in someone
else to activation of an unconscious
complex let's say but
one of the things you point out in the
book and and it's possible to go deeper
than this too one of the things you
point out in the book is that
when you allow or ask or invite someone
to be your mentor you also allow them to
manifest that element of them that's
most mentor-like and they can do that
independently to some degree of their
other flaws just like when you're a
parent a father you can act paternally
as a figure of authority even though you
are by no means a perfect figure of
authority the child still needs you to
be the best authority figure that you
can be despite your flaws and and you
will manifest that but
it it that's also not
false because
the ideal that we're all chasing
we we don't know what its ultimate
reality is
you know if you have an instinct towards
further development let's say what that
means is that there's something about
you that
could be greater than it
currently is
and
we don't know the limits to what that
currently greater could be
and that's where the
the idea of mentorship let's say shades
into something like religious worship
because i suppose if you think about the
christian world the ultimate mentor is
christ and you could say that being a
christian or you could say that being a
psychologist and if you said it being a
psychologist you would say well it's by
definition that the ultimate mentor is
christ and what christianity has been as
it unfolds itself over the last 2000
years is an attempt to engage
all of the people within that belief
system in a dialogue about what that
ideal actually constitutes
you know and there's tradition that
feeds into that the biblical stories and
the corpus of tradition that goes along
with that but all of it is a collective
attempt to specify that ideal so that
people can use it as a target to further
their development and that's not
delusional that that furthering of
development is unbelievably useful
practically
let's start at the very basic like what
was your experience what's been your
experience with this purple woman
sure would you would you mind just for a
little context if if you haven't
if you don't think you've shared it too
much could you tell me a little bit
about your experience oh i'm gonna go
first okay is that i haven't i haven't i
haven't really gotten into it on a
podcast yet and i wrote down the entire
thing right after the first if you want
what do you prefer
um no no let's do it let's do it i'll
get into it um i'll give you the it's
not going to be the like you know 10
page thing i wrote down but last so last
year
i think it was november uh
i was
i was kind of at a point in my life
where i was making serious decisions i
had separated i was separated from my
husband uh for about a year and a half
and
i kind of like sorted out my head in
that year and a half and i got to a
place where i felt stable enough to be
able to do a high dose of a psychedelic
at that point it's psilocybin
so
uh
i i felt stable enough i was like you
know what i'm going to be able to go
into this and learn something
so i
had seven grams in tea
and
that's a good amount oh my god for the
listeners
maybe it may be starting i'm actually a
fan of larger doses i'm not i i don't
like to be prescriptive to anybody else
but for myself personally i i think yeah
the
five grams was what terence mckenna
would call the heroic yes which i
thought was the
most poorly named i i i wish he wouldn't
have
made it sound like such a heroic journey
or whatever but i actually think that's
a good place to start so anyway really
i i do
oh wow i'd had like i've done them a
bunch before that i'd never done that
many i'd done
two i i didn't really like anything
under two i found two to three and a
half got me to this point where i had a
lot of control over it and it was kind
of this uncomfortable
period where i was like oh maybe i don't
want to venture into that and i could
try really hard and stop myself but i
find for me anything over
four
uh and i don't have an option
yeah i i don't like giving myself the
option i i find that uh it's anxiety
those middle grounds are unsettling and
more confusing and they can be helpful
as well but they've they've they've
actually
the the half the half dose so in in many
psilocybin and mdma trials they've done
full dose placebo and then for a while
they were doing half doses and they
they've cut half doses from
really
studies that i know for that very reason
they've actually they've actually seen
people have a
uh if anything sometimes negative impact
from
from the half doses or or interesting
not as much help so so usually there's
there's some help within the placebo
group because you're still getting lots
of therapy and everything and then
there's a
huge impact in the in the full dose and
the half dose
it seems it seems to be that for a lot
of people it's just kind of confusing
and unsettling
the full doses it kind of takes a little
bit of the control from you and you you
tend to surrender to it a little bit
more and there's a certain
clarity
um to it so uh so yeah so go on yeah so
um
i
i had no control right it started and it
was it was interesting it started and i
saw these trolls and i was laying on a
mattress and they were there were these
trolls in the in the corner watching me
i've never gotten trolls
patrols i've never gotten the trolls
yourself you've never got i've gotten
trolls
they're not the purple lady they're like
little gremlin-like things um and i've
had them actually both experiences that
i saw the purple lady i also saw trolls
but it was weird i could see trolls in
the corner so i could this is when i
could still see so i could see the
ceiling i could see these trolls
watching me i got up to use the bathroom
came back the trolls were still there so
they were
stuck in one area watching me and then
when i fell into it
uh
when i fell into it
i probably cried for most of the
experience you know and it was from what
i've read about really high-dose
mushroom experiences it was totally
typical like i i went through every
relationship
in my life and saw how i was
contributing negatively to it
uh i ended it with an overwhelming sense
of
if you're going to put anything into the
universe it should be love because
anything you put that's negative just
adds to the negativity in the universe i
went
what i would say was outer space but it
kind of looked like uh
the beatles yellow submarine it was so
the beatles yellow submarine where it
was kind of a cart kind of cartoon-like
i couldn't see anything right like i was
way out in outer space
uh and there were all these different
beings there
and
it's hard to remember
i'd have to go back and see what i wrote
maybe i'll put that put it in the show
notes because it was more in depth but
there were there were all these
different beings and it filled me with a
sense i lost myself completely
right so i wouldn't say i had i don't
know if that qualified as an ego death
but i didn't exist anymore
and i went to this place where nothing
mattered like nothing mattered
and i thought and it was a relief that
nothing mattered anymore
and then i kind of built it back up and
thought because i have a daughter
and i thought wait a minute some things
matter to me they might not matter in
the greater scheme of things but my
daughter certainly matters to me and
that's okay
and maybe it's better that some things
matter even if
they don't according to this this place
i was in
uh and then at that point my dad was
really ill
uh and he was having a he he's he had a
physical dependency on benzodiazepines
that just that almost kill them right
like those those drugs are just
people don't know how dangerous they are
but uh he had a paradoxical reaction and
it was killing him at that time and it
was very confusing for our family
because we were like what's going on we
didn't know what was going on for a
while and so i saw him in this trip and
he was encompassed in this black [ __ ]
demon
and i looked at the demon and i thought
oh my god
that tar demon used to have me
and i used to be really ill i had i was
on a lot of medication i was extremely
depressed i had arthritis and i got
healthy i got off of all those meds but
i looked at the tar demon and i had this
overwhelming sense of
i know you
and so it's not my dad who's
like who's the bad guy kind of in this
situation he's he's being had by this
tar demon so i went in to grab the tar
demon to pull him away and he grabbed my
arm and started sucking me in
and i was like okay i can't pull him out
and then this purple
so i was filled with rage at this tar
demon and then this purple lady came
and this is over the expanse of what
felt like a thousand years because it
was like four hours of not being able to
see
uh and this purple lady came and for me
she was
it was kind of 2d and very digital and
she floated over me and it looked a lot
like that hockenism
photo it was kind of flat she was just
ahead and she floated over me and i was
filled with a sense of
it's okay you're doing everything right
everything's going to be okay it was
overwhelming sense of that and she just
she didn't say anything right she was
just looking at me and i could just feel
that through her eyes and she just hung
out there
and then this trip slowly ended and that
was the first time i saw her but i ended
up seeing her again
on aco dmt
um but that was the first time i saw her
and i was like i have seen god after
that it was like like nothing nothing
matters fill the universe with love
don't contribute negativity
um
it completely got rid of my fear of
death because it kind of felt like an
after
life experience
and then i saw this purple
god lady and
it had a really lasting impression in me
and then about
a month later
uh i did aco dmt and hamilton morris
actually
suggested i try that and i was very
careless with the dosage because you
need
the tiniest amount it's this powder and
it's so strong that
i didn't understand how strong it was so
i didn't have a scale that was quite
accurate enough so i kind of eyeballed
it on the scale and i ended up doing
probably a third more than i should have
and i was in a shopping center because i
thought it was micro dosing i was in a
shopping center and the trolls showed up
yeah luckily i was with andre at the
time oh also after that experience i got
back together with my husband i saw him
like the a really clear vision of him
and he was this like strong gold statue
character and i was like
oh
who doesn't want to be with a strong
gold statue exactly you can't give that
up
yeah
so so second time i saw these trolls in
the shopping center and was like i have
to go home right now
uh and i i got home and i laid in bed
and it was
probably not a high it was a i don't
like that like drug as much as uh
shrooms it's a it was a little bit more
digital but the same thing happened i
was in bed laying down
and i was in a pretty bad place because
i was really worried about my dad and
the purple lady showed up again and she
didn't she wasn't particularly helpful
she just kind of floated over me and and
did the same like
you're not doing anything wrong
everything's gonna be okay kind of thing
um and then i've
done i've had psychedelic experiences
sin since then i talk a lot about it on
the podcast i don't actually do it that
often
but the profound experiences in there
yeah they're a lot to think about a lot
and and then it's so it's been
absolutely absurd finding other people
online
with similar experiences and people were
like well how do you know it's the same
woman and obviously i don't
but the feeling that comes along with
seeing her seems to be similar it's not
just this purple lady it's
also the feeling she gives you
is that how it felt like for you did you
picture yourself as one of the good guys
well um
look we had a very idealistic view of
who we were back then you know we took
that oath
it was something special because it was
this brotherhood that we were entering
into you know i got your back you got
mine united got made they told me mike
wherever you travel in the world
somebody will be there to have your back
don't ever worry about your wife your
daughter your sister your mother you
know nobody will ever disrespect them
and you're part of a family a
brotherhood and yeah that's a very
powerful feeling i mean you know i the
night that i got made it was
exhilarating to me you know i had an
additional you know blood bond with my
father
and you know i think to a certain extent
that's true
um but you know like anything else you
know money and power you know they
corrupt
and it corrupted that life in many ways
i saw a lot of things happen that uh
that shouldn't have happened you know
people that got hurt suffered
consequences
for more political reasons um
and uh you know so this idealistic view
that i had of the life didn't last
you know when i walked away it wasn't
because i was mad at anybody or or
anything i walked away basically to
preserve my family but
uh it's not all what it's cracked up to
be and you know i don't know if you can
say that the same of the of the police
but um
you know it just isn't and and like i
said sad um but it
isn't how did you manage briefly how did
you manage to get out because what you
hear
or i don't know the only place i've
learned about anything that has to do
with mafia is from the a movie
realistically i haven't actually talked
to anyone just you now but what i've
seen in movies is you don't get out
you you either die or you end up in jail
um and
so how did you how did you manage it i
know that you went to jail and you did
your time but how did you manage to get
away without anyone harboring
resentments
well you're right mikhail you're not
allowed to to leave that life i mean i i
basically broke my oath you know america
i mean i speak about the life i don't
speak about it in terms of putting
people in trouble but i do talk about
the life
and um you know i think for me it was
two reasons number one one of the
horrors of that life
is that you know you make a mistake or
whatever political reason happens in
there and and your best friend walks you
into a room and you don't walk out again
and um unfortunately in my 20 years in
that life you know i've experienced that
with others
and um so what i said is this you know
people are very upset with me i mean my
father practically disowned me when i
walked away i mean everybody thought i
was going to start testifying against
people because normally that's what
happens you make a deal with the
government you start informing you go
into the witness protection program but
that's not what i was about i didn't
want to do that i didn't want to hurt
anybody i just wanted out so the boss of
my family you know come on persico who
who passed away last year he was very
upset with me contract on my life i mean
i had the whole thing i had some you
know severe struggles
but here's what what i did
fortunately i knew the life intimately
well i could never have stayed in new
york there was no way i would have made
it i move out to california
um i changed my own entire lifestyle
meaning that i didn't create patterns in
my life in case people were looking at
me i didn't walk my dog every morning at
seven o'clock i didn't go to the same
restaurant every tuesday night i stayed
out of nightclubs because i know their
bad place for me i know who hangs out
there i'm fairly well known somebody
makes a call to new york i go into the
parking lot boom i'm gone so i avoided
all of that i was very disciplined about
it and um
you know the second reason for me is you
know i'm a strong person of faith and i
believe god had a different plan and a
purpose for my life that's become very
obvious to me
and uh you know what happened over a
period of time mckellar
is i just outlasted everybody i mean
there was you know i don't know if you
know what went on in the states
especially in new york but when the
government in the mid-80s um
you know created the racketeering law
and the bail reform act and the
sentencing reform act they were putting
people away left and right for 100 years
50 years 70 years
and you know guys had their own
things to worry about and since i wasn't
hurting anybody i didn't testify against
people i wasn't you know causing anybody
any damage over a period of time they
just had to deal with their own troubles
and leave me alone and then everybody i
dealt with in that life
um is either dead or in prison for the
rest of their life everybody
so
you know just very fortunate very
blessed
yeah that's a crazy story
that's got to be an incredibly stressful
way to live if you're trying to think of
every single opportunity where somebody
could get you and avoid all of those how
long did you have to do that for
well for quite some time you know when i
was out on parole it was it was tough
and uh you know i would say there were
years because we what happened was too
uh you know that the fbi did me kind of
dirty they will put my name on the
witness list of trials that were coming
up so even though i was sending word you
know back to my father i'm not going to
hurt anybody nobody believed me because
nobody just walks away and then my name
is coming up and all the discovery that
the you know the defendants were getting
so but then trials kept coming and i
never appeared
so while that was happening i had a lot
of heat but then all of a sudden i never
appear i got violated on my parole sent
back to prison and people saying hey
this guy's not looking to hurt anybody
he just wants out and then they kind of
tend it to their own business now don't
get me wrong i couldn't go back to new
york and say hey guys i'm moving back
into the neighborhood you know i
wouldn't have last too long but you know
i believe in god and god doesn't tell
you to be stupid you got to use your
head you know so
so um you know again just uh extremely
fortunate and uh and very blessed that
i've come this far
[Music]
you